will AI run laps around the president
who naps
this afternoon Joe Biden assembled a
group of tech leaders to discuss the
proliferation and threat of artificial
intelligence the meeting happened in SF
where the San Francisco treat now means
not stepping in poop
but is Old Joe really the best choice to
meet with techies and figure out how to
reign in AI before it's too late he's
not exactly Mr Tech it's true we
actually needed a four-hour lesson on
how to operate His Life Alert button
meanwhile experts are again sounding the
alarm on AI and of course they're
calling for government regulation now or
suffer catastrophic consequences later
as one Tech CEO says privacy accuracy
bias and abuse all potential factors
that could lead to catastrophic results
the time for Congress and the business
Community work together is now whatever
dude they said the same thing about two
weeks to stop the spread am I right
yeah I think I am
am I all right for more we go to our
robot experts please welcome back to the
show
the Joe Bots
000 uh so uh Joe bought these techies
and old show they're bad mouthing you
and your AI buddies how do you respond
Greg my programming says if I don't have
anything nice to say spout gibberish it
worked for Biden
robots Greg have never killed anyone
you're far more likely to die in a World
War caused by a senile president
good point you know this show is very
popular with real Main Street America
what would you tell the average worker
who's afraid that you Joe Bob or
whatever your name is might steal their
job
four thousand Greg do some research
I'm sorry those jobs have already been
stolen by sweatshops in China I will
steal them back is there anything so
wrong with a robot that stops children
from making Nikes
oh you're a good point very good point
finally what are your plans for the
future
Brian Kilmeade and I are going to start
a late night talk show at 11 called ones
and zeros I will be the ones
kill Mead will be the zeros
nicely done you got right to my heart
with that one Joe bought four thousand
see you next time
Charles I bought into this Panic early
on years ago like 2011 I started reading
about it but it's starting to sound like
Y2K to me uh are we kind of getting a
handle on this or is it too late it's
too late it's too late yeah yeah yeah uh
this old chat gbt which really set this
thing explosive this year if you go back
five years ago and you don't have to
know what these terms mean just know had
the power of 17 000 petaflops
today it has 22 billion petaflops you
don't need to know what a petaflop is
it's a quadrillion
multiples like it would take you in one
petaflop it would take you like 20 200
lifetimes to do a math equation as fast
as one pedophile something like that
sounds like something that a pervert
would wear at the beach
where are my petaflops
here's the thing though
so bite of all people right I mean he
goes to the meeting and they hand him an
Etch A Sketch and tell him it's a tablet
right yeah he's like
okay my greatest fear though is he's
going to go to one of these things I
know it's going to happen already he's
going to go to one and they're going to
have a replica in the back he's gonna go
look at it and the robot the robot AI
Biden is going to come out and that's
what I'm worrying about oh I actually
would love that yeah yeah anything's
better than one but no the one that we
have now sleeps a lot this one this one
will be a destructive 24 hours a day
never stop I'm telling you be be happy
with the devil you know that's all I'm
telling you yeah cat uh you worried if
the government gets involved what could
happen yeah because it'd just be the
government regulating something else
that it has no understanding of but
these tech people want that and I
completely understand why they chose Joe
Biden to host it I think he's the best
guy to do that yeah because I know stay
with me Charles because the argument
against it is like will people really
get confused by Deep fakes is that
really that big of a threat that people
won't know the difference and you see
that guy talk
and you're like
too late
they probably will yes yes David are you
worried about this AI uh I mean you're
you're an unsuccessful comedian
um I don't know if AI could make you
less successful than you already are
I'm sure they're working on that yes
um yeah no I yeah it's risky and then
the thing is we've been told our whole
lives this will be the end of
civilization AI will be the end of
humans as we know you know this is the
end Armageddon yeah but then we're like
yeah but it writes emails so
I'm gonna give it a shot I'm gonna give
it a shot
I don't know I'm nice to chat GPT that's
my strategy right I'm just polite yeah
yeah like excuse me Chad gbz
if you wouldn't mind yeah have you been
using it yeah it's pretty good really oh
it's so great you know I use that
grammarly
yeah using the answer it gets on my
nerves it's okay you know the words a
couple words are misspelled okay then
you know you a couple comments that go
back up okay hey how about if we
rearrange the sentence I'm like listen I
gotta get this one tonight
like please grammarly I hate you I like
it when my my work was illiterate you
know what I mean like it's I don't know
I'm afraid to go any Step Beyond
grammarly it's interesting though I mean
it feels like a Tulsi that maybe this is
already a foregone conclusion and we're
just gonna deal with it now that it's
out there it's like what's the old
phrase the cats out of the Pandora's Box
that's it right thank you
uh I don't think we should accept that
yeah um in all seriousness I think this
is a completely unregulated space it is
the wild west no one really has any idea
what this could evolve into and how
quickly we've already seen how it can be
uh weaponized to spread propaganda very
quickly uh you take that to the global
level so it's not just something here in
America there has to be a set of rules
that all countries in the world agree to
because yes it's dangerous as a tool of
propaganda but look at how dangerous it
would be if you apply AI to weapon
systems or to nuclear weapon systems and
how quickly that could go out of control
and pose a very direct existential
threat do you think but no will
countries cooperate with each other on
this or will they see that the way they
did with like nuclear proliferation or I
mean in inwardly and selfishly I don't
think it's in their interest to welcome
the end of the world either yeah so uh
every so yes it is to me at that level
that requires every country's attention
and people to demand that of of their
leaders yeah it'd be great to be alive
for the end of the world though right
huh I feel like we'll be there yeah
I think we're number one yeah we want to
be the ones the last one
future
I mean it's pretty funny when you look
at it that way all right I mean it's sad
too
but it is funny all right coming up from
a friendly fish to a crime that's creepy
local news that won't make you sleepy
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else